Bosnia and Herzegovina is one of the
world's most almost landlocked countries
with this tiny bit of Coastline here on
the Adriatic Sea interestingly this
territorial Corridor runs right through
Croatia leaving the country split into
two parts given how odd this is it
raises a pretty obvious question why is
Croatia split into two by Bosnia so as
of the early modern period Croatia was
ruled by the kings of Hungary who as
you'll know often came into conflict
with their neighbors notably the Ottoman
Empire to the South the Ottomans had
been warring with the hungarians and
notably the venetians for the past
several centuries and one of the
outcomes of these wars was that this
area called the Republic of Ragusa saw
ottoman protection from potential
Invasion from Venice and for this the
Republic had a clever solution to the
north they ceded to the Ottomans the
coastal town of Naim and the corridor of
territory behind it and to the South
they seeded suitorina this way any
invasional raid would trigger an ottoman
response this status remained for about
a century and a half until ragusa's
existence as an independent nation came
to an end as a result of shockingly
Napoleon Bonaparte after his victories
over Austria in a brief occupation he
Incorporated it into France's illyrian
territories as you'll know he lost soon
afterwards and the Hope was that Ragusa
would be restored to Independence but
fun fact no this was because the
austrians decided that actually they
were going to keep it and ragusa's
territories were thus incorporated into
the Austrian and later austro-hungarian
Empires Bosnia next door was occupied by
Austria-Hungary in 1878 and so the gaps
between its Dalmatian territories were
plugged so was there any formal attempt
to change it well no this was because it
was mostly a formality and also because
Bosnia was still technically ottoman
land under Austrian occupation when it
was annexed three decades later the
austro-hungarians had no reason to
change something so small which had been
working for them because administering
Bosnia didn't need much change as you'll
be aware it wasn't long until World War
One in which Austria-Hungary did not
fare well it lost and was subsequently
carved up with these lands going to the
kingdom of Yugoslavia and a decade after
yugoslavia's creation the land corridors
which had blown into Bosnia were
rectified the northern one was now a
part of the literal banovina and the
southern a part of the Zeta banovina
this was mostly done along ethnic lines
something which will become important to
Yugoslavia shortly so given that these
territorial Oddities were fixed why does
Modern Bosnia still own the corridor
well the reason was Tito after World War
II saw the kingdom of Yugoslavia
occupied in its leaders exiled the
government which took over after its
Liberation was a communist one and this
new government wanted to distance itself
from the kingdom and so it opted to
change the internal divisions of
Yugoslavia the government agreed on the
1878 borders for Bosnia and Hertz
Governor as well as Croatia because as
far as their ideology was concerned the
ethnic divisions within the country were
artificial that said the southern
Corridor wasn't returned to Bosnia and
was instead given to Montenegro as part
of some smaller land swaps and this is
what remained until yugoslavia's
collapse at which point the
International Community made it
abundantly clear that any redrawing of
the borders would mean no recognition
which is why after Croatia gained its
independence its Coastline has a small
Bosnia an interruption I hope you
enjoyed this episode with a special
thanks to my patrons James bizzinette
Kelly moneymaker call show wolf Sky
Chappelle kartoitska Jerry lambdin Alex
Schwinn Adam Stalter Jordan Longley rod
D Martin why in hockey Marcus Arsenal
Captain psydog Marvin Castle Spencer
Lightfoot Winston caywood boogly Wiggly
Daniel tobian commune Miss izet Gustav
Swan Aaron the white Anthony Beckett the
mcwhopper Maggie Paskowski Coppertone
spinning three plates she went in words
about books podcast and Charles the
first